Good morning, John. I have some good news.
Some bad news, but some good news. There's this number
that people use as part of, uh, our understanding of public health
in the world. Kind of a surrogate for the overall health
of a population, though not a great one. It's called
life expectancy. Very simply, it is the average age at which
a person in our country will die.  That number has gone up a lot
in the last 200 years for people but
interestingly, it's also gone up for you...
person watching.  And it goes up for you
every day. And probably not
for the reason you're thinking.  So the life expectancy of the average dude in the
U.S. is 76. But for me,
it's 78. That's nice!  I got an extra couple of years
on the average dude.  Look at me! How did I do that?
Well, here's a statistic that might sound a little more surprising at first but will
help you figure out why. The average person will die
at 76, but the average 76 year old
will die at 86.  And the average 86
year old ,
they will die at 91. So I was hanging out with Thomas Franker earlier
today of college info geek, he's 26 years old.
His life expectancy is 77 years old.
Mine is 78. What is up with that is that he has to live
for like 11 more years
before he gets to my age. Very sadly,  some
people will die, not very many, but some,  between the
ages of 26 and 37. I, on the other hand,  because I am 37, will never have died
between the ages of 26 and 37. I just can't do it.
So every hour you live, your life expectancy goes up.
The number of hours you have left to live goes down
but not at one hour per hour.
Every hour that passes – this makes my brain hurt –
you are closer to death, but you are less than one hour closer to death.
And that's a small comfort.
I had this dumb idea, when I was younger,
that since the life expectancy of a person in America is 78,
that once you got to 78 you could just die at any time.
Like a stiff wind blows and you're just like "I'm out"
But it is not until
You are 114 that you have
A better than average chance of dying in the next
365 days. WHAT?
Now to be fair, there are many years before that when you have
A better than average chance of dying in the next thousand days
Which is why most people don't get
To 114. But by and large, statistically
Everyone can expect to have at least a year
When you turn 114 though, you have a more than 50% chance of
Hitting 115, that's the statistics
Another thing worth noting is that life expectancy takes a snapshot of
This very moment with the death rates for
Every person at every age. It is actually not a measure of when
You will die, because that death rate
Will change over time, and everyone knows that. And mostly
We hope, barring some kind of catastrophic solar flare induced apocalypse
Death rates will continue to go down. Like the life expectancy for a 25 year old
In 1960 was about 70 years old, but it turned out
That that 25 year old, or the population of 25 year olds
Ended up dying significantly after the age of 70, so yeah, that thing
Which doesn't actually have to do with life expectancy the statistic
Makes your life longer
And nobody has to die, so that John, is a plus
I guess if you weren't getting enough death talk on Dear Hank and John
Here it is on Vlogbrothers. Speaking of, three things, the first one
This animation that somebody made of a
Dear Hank and John segment where we talk bizarre pizza deliveries
Which I liked. Second, Patreon made a really great video
About our production studio
Here in Missoula, and I'd like to share that as well
It's just fantastic. And lastly,
I know this took a little bit of time, but we finally have all of the
Grant recipients for the Project for Awesome, and have sent all of their
Cheques off. We sent a lot of them earlier, but we have sent the last ones
Not all perks have been sent, but most of them have
I've been working really hard on mine, and I'm sorry. And number four
I'm going to VidCon next week, AHHHHH!
There's still tickets avaliable if you want to come check it out
And John, I think that I will see you next in the real world
In Los Angeles, before I see you next on the computer screen
So looking forward to that